g'day I'm Dan but you can call me Don oh
and I'm here to be your guide to Ozzie
car slang vol 1 so you don't look like a
bloody gala when forza horizon three
launches whoo let's get started
doughnuts now for the circular marks
they leave on the road doughnuts are
achieved by simultaneously engaging the
accelerator and the brake and turning
the steering wheel hard to the side in
order to make the cusp in on its axis
one should refer to the action as
shocking or fanging a doe it acceptable
places to do a dolly ah a servo car park
a bottle o car park mm Darren's mums
cul-de-sac may knees or lapping
depending on the region it's a simple
action of performing a circuit or lap of
the main street forza horizon 3 will
allow you to visit probably the most
famous place for manny's Surfers
Paradise home of the annual schoolies
festival it's common to see p platers
performing a ritual in order to attract
the attention of the opposite sex
and don't forget to turn up your
subwoofer many people make fun of the
Australian habit of shortening words and
adding superfluous vowels but did you
know that the origins are actually quite
practical due to the extreme heat almost
all of Australia experiences where to
shorten so as not to exhaust the speaker
while the addition of vowels causes air
to be blown into the face of any
listeners affording them a small
reprieve from the heat taking this into
account here's the Australian slang for
some of the over 350 cars available in
Forza horizon 3
let's examine what you've learned open
the activity booklet you were given
prior to today's training session and
turn to page 12 answer the survey and
pass it back to the certified oz you
slang trainer at the front of the room
pause the tape now so that's volume 1 in
our guide to Ozzy car slang next time in
volume 2 will teach you to know your
boot from your bonnet how to deal with
lower izing homes and how to chuck e ue
without stacking it so you're mrs.
doesn't crack the ships until then
you